all right folks here we are at the
Dallas improv this is my first stand-up
set back in like 84 84 days I got I just
put a special out so all my material is
gone I mean one thing I can come back
onstage is jumping on my old act I just
put out the neck and put out on YouTube
it's all out there so now I got no
material and those skills so I wrote
just a ton of [ __ ] I got Corona
I got riots I got anal I mean you name
it and I'm terrified I'm rusty and I
have new material that's not fleshed out
this is gonna be a goddamn disaster and
I wait all watch it and be there with me
but this is gonna be ugly but they
witness a big bomb folks yeah pandemics
got nothing on this this show right here
this is gonna be bad and we got 25%
capacity
you know the whole thing's [ __ ] this
is the bad situation
this could get ugly so let's see what
happens hey comedy huh
alright we're really doing it thanks for
coming out cleavage shoulders how you
doing there
I love the hoops I love a lady with
hoops you can always talk crazy woman's
by the sides for hoops
alright that's where this comes from
[Music]
somebody write that down just thought of
that
alright
and don't worry I'm not cheating here
these just lost because I've drawn there
you go all right yeah yep yep and I hope
I'm not I don't mean to offend anybody
if you are offended just you know kill
yourself well like now you're a lot of
event I'm just joking but you know hey
welcome back speaking of taking a [ __ ]
alright
worked so hard on that phone booth
joking but it's okay that's cute then I
do the [ __ ] joke
that's why comedy is a kick in the taint
I'll tell you that but it's honest I
appreciate the honesty you're all good
eggs as a bunch of schools right by in
my apartment I live in New York and all
this all these schools I live in like a
school district there's like a school
for engineering as a school for beauty
school for our carpentry there's even a
school for [ __ ] people which is
great I'm like who would send their kid
to a school to learn to be [ __ ] all
right I tried a new one
[ __ ] it's tough you really walk in a
tough line there with the [ __ ] jokes I
thought I could do it I'll figure that
one out don't you worry
by the end of the weekend that [ __ ]
school is gonna be cooking this Hey look
what I'm 85 days out of stand-up here
folks my dick cannot get hard comedic
Lee I'm working on it
all right by the way I went to a gay
wedding in January so fun unwilling gay
any gays here well not one gay guy two's
case all right yeah yeah not one gay
that is statistically impossible all
right
right now there's some guy in the back
like should this be the time I come out
uh yeah big fan big fan of the gays you
know I read some article gay marriages
raked up 3.8 billion for the country how
cool is that
yeah gays are to marriage would black
peel or to sports you know take it to
another level you're the best at it
all right that's something there I gotta
figure that one out good damn it second
shows a little rowdy a lot of drunks
some people wouldn't shut up and it was
like right you know he [ __ ] with the guy
you yell out of he calm a horrible
insult this girlfriend tells him to shut
up you're embarrassing you know class
the beauty of Corona and the riots and
all that [ __ ] is that we all know what
I'm talking about you know sometimes you
tell jokes somebody's like I don't know
what it's like to dog Corona and
everything we're all on board and a lot
of these will take but that's what it's
all about
I wrote a whole new batch there's such a
weird country so we know we can only
support one group at a time like right
now we're like trying to help black
people two years ago is be to those
women what about women who still get
[ __ ] with yeah now it's like I have a
woman that's got sexually assaulted hey
shut up sister we're on black now we can
only do one of the time what about trans
rights let's though 2019 [ __ ] nerd I'm
just gonna help somebody all right Oh
checks are coming around this audience
it's got the attention span of a gnat
stick all right
Saturday night Dallas we did two shows
both were killer crowds are great great
town nice people good eggs and a couple
whiskeys
and ho go out hit the town but I'm done
I'm going in we got one show tomorrow
and that'll do it for the weekend and
I'm saying I'm sad to end it I used to
look at comedy I got so routine with it
the I flew a flew out every weekend and
you know yeah we got two shows a night
shitty hotel and now I didn't realize
what I had I loved it and I take it I
took it for granted now it's grateful
I'm hit the Residence Inn we're going to
bed I'll rub one out to uh Norma Daniels
and it's called a noble life you want to
join look as much as I [ __ ] on this this
country of ours I think it's still
pretty good you know you know this
country is great 90 day fiancé you ever
seen this when you look at some of the
ghouls people are willing to [ __ ] just
to get a taste of America you're like
damn we must have it pretty [ __ ] good
huh some ladies wouldn't let a guy with
no neck inside of her just to get a
taste of Detroit like all right that's
quite a nation we got here we're getting
there we're getting there
yeah you guys are catching on you guys
are all right this crowds like anal
takes a minute you know after a while
you're like I love it here we are in the
hotel room a lot of semen some lotion
somewhere best deodorant standing behind
it
hey Corona now some businesses are
opening with curbside pickup prostitutes
said hey we've been doing that the whole
time all right we'll try it we'll give
it a whirl so hopefully there's a crowd
tonight and you know
well yuk it up and probably offend
somebody but it's sold out is it what
know that oh my god
well let's go do some comedy
[Music]
madness walk back pretty drunk eight
times
here we go just cavity
[Music]
flat picture what needed the rope
Florina Brooklyn slow down
[Music]
address some of the [ __ ] going on in the
world so many good-looking people here
I'm not you not you but a couple are
pretty hot fast beautiful people in this
town you guys are underrated just
beautiful ladies you know like I travel
the country there's a lot of a lot of
fatties up there you know and or a fat
country that's alright you know we're
fat we love food we're obsessed with
food all the factories in America have
closed except cheesecake okay that's it
that's the only one that made it yeah
these poor kids I gotta go to school at
home now they're all homeschooled you
know I said how long until a teacher in
Florida has cybersex with one of her
students huh and you know what's gonna
happen any Jews here there you go either
there no Jews here or Jews Oh like I'm
not falling for that one again no no
those days are over we did it it's all
over
I need more material I suck I'm starting
out killing and then it just goes right
through the [ __ ] box but I'll get it
together that's why you do these pigs to
get more material god dammit
hey I wish you with my parents hey hey
great frame hey hey there is really a
good weekend it's all over five shows in
the bag
rusty as hell first show but I'll say it
all snaps right back in once you're up
there and you feel that you're flowing
baby whoo so good to get back in there
and now I feel like I got a cocaine bump
and I gotta go back to New York where
there's no comedy again so I'm gonna
have withdrawals all over again but I
got a little fix so that was fun I got a
lot of work done tried some new jokes
boy it was great just a tough time new
special came out and I'm rusty and I'm
doing new material so I'm all over the
road but that was great crowds were
great I love Texas and now I got to fly
back to New York so I'm gonna hit the
bar and drink with the staff and the
local comics one of the treats of doing
comedy is hanging out with comics so uh
let's go get drunk okay anyone else hard